Opposers, it's summer
blockbuster season.
That doesn't just mean
I'm heading
to my former employer
to demand my job back.
No, it also means
there are lots of big, expensive
movies hitting the theaters.
So, here to take down liberal
Hollywood one last time,
citizen journalists
Aaron Jackson and Josh Sharp!
-(cheers and applause)
-No. No!
(bleep) that, Jordan!
Yeah. We're not going to waste
our last four minutes
on television talking
about (bleep) Jurassic World!
I'm not about to watch hours of
a predatory dinosaur onscreen.
Bill O'Reilly's been canceled!
-(laughing): I love that.
-Yeah.
Okay, so, tonight, we're not
just going at the movies.
We're widening our scopes
for our new segment:
BOTH:
"Going at the Everything!"
-(fanfare, squeal, thumping)
-(applause and cheering)
The gloves are off,
and our hands are filthy,
so we're ready
to take down everything.
-Are you scared, Jordan?
-No.
I mean, just what do you mean
"at the everything"?
-Chuck, stay with us.
-(Klepper mutters) Okay, okay.
-Come on, Chuck! Come on!
-Stay with us!
-Okay, let's start
with The Carters. -Mm-hmm.
We're ready to rip this album
apart from Bey to Z.
Now, for those of you
keeping score,
this is the third hit record
about Jay-Z's infidelity.
They are America's favorite
cheating couple, and, honestly,
they should just
keep on milking it.
Beyoncé, if you (bleep) Drake,
you'd probably get your own
cinematic universe.
Yeah. And I know you can
stream it everywhere now,
but the fact
that this was a TIDAL exclusive
for even an afternoon
is (bleep) stupid.
Music is a fundamental right,
not like health care.
Libs, if you want free Medicare,
-come up with a Napster
for hospitals. -Yes!
Not that we know
what Napster is.
-We're very young.
-Extremely young.
Moving on.
Gay Pride is this month!
Wow. So, enjoy your celebration
of love and self-acceptance
and harmony.
-I'm talking to you,
corporations! -Yeah.
(laughter)
You leftists think Pride is
a big liberal wankfest,
but it's not.
It's just a capitalist bukkake!
Yeah, as if Colgate gives a shit
about you.
-No, they want your cash,
you childless queens! -Yes.
(laughter)
Brands have always been there,
and they always will be there.
-Equifax threw the first brick
at Stonewall! -Yeah.
Conservative companies
should join in on the fun.
-Yeah.
-You don't have to like gays.
You just have to love money.
Yeah, Chick-fil-A,
get in on this!
We even made you a new logo!
(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
It's very good.
Yes. In June,
all corporations are gay...
-for pay.
-Yes.
Next up-- fad diets.
Gluten-free, Whole30.
Jesus, what's harder--
only eating veggies,
or constantly (bleep)
telling me about it?
Just eat bread and die!
(laughter)
Jared and Ivanka, you off-brand
Barbie and Ken dolls,
you've been coyly evil
for too long.
It's time be evil evil!
Set a nursing home on fire!
Sell an orphan on eBay!
Drench this country in blood,
you (bleep) vampires! Commit!
-(applause and cheering)
-Yes. More hot takes!
-More. We need more.
-More hot takes.
-Time for a speed round!
-Speed round. Okay.
Antarctica,
stop melting, you stupid bitch!
Yeah. Horses, you're not cars,
and you never will be!
Stay still and look pretty!
-Oil, be more!
-Mm.
Ooh, gender-reveal parties.
Ugh. I don't want
to bite into a cupcake
to find out
if your baby has a dick!
-Yes.
-Straight people are perverts!
Yes. Yes.
Facebook, you're evil.
You feed people fake news,
enable sham elections
and make everyone
more lonely and sad.
-Keep up the good work!
-Mm-hmm.
Next up, we got...
Chuck? Chuck, what's happening?
Wait. We need more things
to go at, Chuck!
Yeah, yeah, we're not done!
CHUCK: That's it, guys.
That's all you gave me.
-What? No, no, no, no.
-(Sharp muttering)
-There has to be something else.
-Yes.
-We can't...
-Something else to go out.
Something in...
something in this room.
-Okay, okay, wait, wait.
-Scanning. Scanning.
-(muttering)
-Scanning.
-JACKSON: Scanning.
-(laughter)
Jordan-- he's got big, stupid
hair, but everybody knows that.
Oh, that cameraman.
And he's probably has a family.
No, that's too easy.
What else? What else? What else?
(Jackson gasps loudly
and sharply)
BOTH:
You.
You're an attention-seeking
media whore!
You don't believe anything
you say.
You only say it so that people
will listen to you,
thus feeding into
the modern media culture
that assigns no value
to anything thoughtful
or substantive or truthful,
and instead rewards ignorant
blowhards for their shock value
because entertainment is all
that matters anymore.
You're a piggy,
a greedy, selfish (bleep) pig
who will fatten yourself
on the death of discourse
until you explode, a steaming
pile of putrid hateful slime!
(cheers and applause)
KLEPPER:
Uh...
are you guys...
are you o... are you okay?
-Stay on...
-Chuck! Stay on us, Chuck!
-Stay on us... forever. Yeah.
-Stay on us forever, Chuck!
-Well, y'all, it's been cute.
-Yeah.
But that's all the time we have.
So, until some other
Viacom property scoops us up,
remember this:
money is God; content is king,
and if you think
the world is on fire,
grab a can of gasoline,
and we'll see you
in the comments section.
Good-bye forever, you sluts!
The fight continues...!